When you're cold, or watching a scary movie,...
...or maybe even when your favorite song plays at a concert,...
...you might get little bumps all over your skin.
That happens when tiny muscles on our body hair tighten up...
...and make the hair stand upright.
They're called goosebumps.
So, why do we get them?
It's an involuntary response to intense emotion.
That's why you might get them when watching a horror movie.
In fact, the word "horror" comes from a Latin word meaning, "to bristle with fear."
Horripilation is the technical term for goosebumps.
They got their name because, well, they look like the skin of a plucked bird.
Goosebumps have a practical purpose for animals.
When an animal's hair sticks up,...
...it makes it look bigger and help protect it against predators.
A raised layer of fur can also help keep an animal warm when it's cold.
For humans, goosebumps don't act as any sort of survival reaction.
Instead, experts say it's simply the result of a rush of adrenaline...
...sparked by an extreme emotion.